hello everyone and welcome back to our
Channel today we have a gripping and
informative topic to discuss the top 10
types of cyber crimes that have shaken
the digital world whether you are a
cyber security Enthusiast or just
curious about the darker side of the
internet this video is for you cyber
crime is evolving rapidly and
understanding the most prevalent threats
is crucial for your Online safety in
this video we'll uncover the top 10
types of cyber crimes that have made
headlines from massive data breaches to
sophisticated hacking operations and if
you're an aspiring cyber security
professional looking for online training
and certifications from prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts to enhance your
credibility then search no more simply
lar postgraduate program in cyber
security from MIT University in
collaboration with EC Council should be
your right choice the course is designed
to accommodate a diverse range of
Learners and this course requires just a
bachelor's degree with a 50% average and
no prior programming experience and one
plus year of work experience is
preferred for more details use the link
in the description box below so let's
Dive Right In and explore the world of
cyber crime with a countdown of the top
10 types of cyber crimes starting with
number one data breaches a data breach
is a significant security incident where
unauthorized access retrieval or
disclosure of sensitive or confidential
information occurs these breaches can
have severe consequences including
Financial losses reputation damage and
privacy violations cyber criminals
exploit vulnerabilities in computer
systems or networks to gain access to
personal financial or business data
common examples involve stolen login
credentials credit card details or
personal information organizations
invest heavily in cyber security
measures to prevent data breaches but
they remain a persistent threat in the
digital age timely detection and
response are essential to mitigate the
impact of these breaches and Safeguard
sensitive information number two
ransomware attacks ransomware attacks
are malicious cyber incidents where
hackers encrypt a victim's data and
demand a ransom in exchange for the
decryption key these attacks can
organizations locking them out of
critical systems and sensitive
information the attackers typically
demand payment in cryptocurrencies to
maintain anonymity ransomware has
evolved into a lucrative criminal
Enterprise targeting businesses
hospitals and even individuals the
consequences of a successful ransomware
attack can be devastating leading to
data loss Financial loss and
reputational damage preventative
measures such as regular backups robust
cyber security and employee training are
essential to mitigate the risk of
falling victim to ransomware now moving
to third one that is fishing scams
fishing scams are deceptive tactics
employed by cyber criminals to trick
individuals into revealing sensitive
information such as passwords credit
card details or personal data typically
fishing involves fraudulent emails
messages or websites that impersonate
legitimate entities like Banks or
reputable organizations the aim is to
lure victims into clicking on malicious
links or providing confidential
information F successful hackers can
exploit this data for financial gain or
identity theft fishing is a prevalent
and ever revolving threat in the digital
world emphasizing the importance of
awareness and caution when interacting
with online communication to safeguard
personal and financial information now
coming to the next one identity theft
identity theft is a serious cyber crime
where an individual's personal
information such as the name social
security number or financial data is
stolen and fraudulently used by cyber
criminals perpetrators often use the
stolen identity for financial gain
including assessing bank accounts
applying for loans or making
unauthorized purchases the consequences
for victims can be devastating including
Financial losss damaged credit scores
and emotional distress preventive
measures like strong passwords
monitoring Financial accounts and being
cautious with personal information
online are essential to protect oneself
from identity theft in today's digitally
connected world and the next is Doos
attacks a distributed denial of service
Doos attack is a malicious attempt
disrupt the regular functioning of a
Network website or online services by
overwhelming it with a flood of traffic
from multiple sources in a dsack a large
number of compromised devices often part
of a Bo net are used to send an
excessive amount of request or data to
the Target causing it to become
inaccessible to legitimate users these
attacks can have severe consequences
including downtime Financial losses and
damage to reputation mitigation
techniques such as traffic filtering and
content delivery networks are essential
to defend against Doos attacks and
ensure the continued availability of
online services and coming to the next
online fraud online fraud refers to
various deceptive activities conducted
over the internet with the intention of
gaining financial advantage at the
expense of victims it encompasses a wide
range of schemes including identity
theft credit card fraud and fishing
scams perpetrators often employ
sophisticated techniques to trick
individuals and organizations into
diverging sensitive information or
making unauthorized Financial
transactions online fraud can lead to
severe Financial losses and personal
data breaches making it a significant
concern for internet users and
businesses alike to protect oneself it's
crucial to remain cautious verify
sources and employ robust security
measures when engaging in online
transactions or sharing personal
information now coming to the next cyber
espon cyber espon is the cortt and
unauthorized infiltration of computer
systems and networks with the intent to
gather sensitive information often for
political economic or military purposes
perpetrated by nation states cyber espon
age involves sophisticated tactics like
malware fishing and hacking to access
classified data Trade Secrets or
government intelligence the stolen
information can be exploited to gain a
competitive advantage or Espionage
activities it poses a significant threat
to Nation security and global stability
necessitating constant vigilance and S
security measures to counter these cste
attacks in the digital Ram now coming to
the next cryptojacking cryptojacking is
a malicious practice where cyber
criminals covertly hijack a victim's
computer or devices processing power to
mine cryptocurrencies like Bitcoin or
Monero this is typically done without
the user's consent or knowledge slowing
down the device and increasing energy
consumption cryptojacking can occur
through infected websites malicious
software downloads or compromised ads
the Mind cryptocurrency goes directly to
the attacker wallet it's a profitable
yet illegal activity that poses a
significant threat to both individuals
and organizations to protect against
cryptojacking users should use reputable
antivirus software and regularly update
their systems to patch vulnerabilities
that could be exploited by crypto
jackers now coming to the next that is
social engineering social engineering is
a deceptive tactic used by cyber
criminals to manipulate individuals or
organizations into diverging
confidential information or performing
actions against their best interest this
psychological manipulation prays on
human trust and emotions it can take
various forms such as fishing emails
impersonation pretexting or baiting
social engineers often use convincing
pretext to trick their targets into
revealing sensitive data such as
passwords or financial details it's a
critical aspect of cyber security
awareness to recognize and resist these
manipulative tactics as social
engineering attacks remain a prevalent
and effective method for hackers to
breach cyber security systems and
compromise personal or corporate data
now coming to the next defix and
manipulated content defix and
manipulated content refer to the
alarming phenomena where artificial
intelligence and advanced software are
used to create highly convincing but
entirely fabricated videos audio
recordings or images these deceptive
media pieces often superimpose on person
likeliness onto another making it appear
as though they are saying or doing
things they never did De fakes have
raised significant concerns about
misinformation privacy and the potential
to deceive the public as technology
advances the ability to detect and
combat defects becomes increasingly
critical in prison deserving trust and
authenticity in the digital age and this
was all for this tutorial hope you guys
found it informative and helpful there
you have it the top 10 types of cyber
crimes that have shaped the digital
landscape stay tuned for more insights
into cyber security and don't forget to
like subscribe and share this video with
anyone interested in staying safe online
remember knowledge is power when it
comes to protecting yourself in the
digital age stay vigilant stay informed
and stay secure if you are an aspiring
cyber security professional looking for
online training and certification from
prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts to
enhance your credibility then search no
more simply learn Advanced executive
program in cyber security in
collaboration with npci should be your
right choice with this program you can
transform your career in 6 months for
India specific region only and this
course provides a high engagement
learning experience with real world
applications and is designed for
individuals who want to start a new and
more fulfilling career and now let's
take a minute to hear from our Learners
who have experienced massive success in
their careers by opening out Simply
courses hi I'm Phillip I'm 61 years old
and last year I upskill with simply
learns postgraduate program in cyber
security after working 30 years in the
it sector and various different profiles
I'm happy to tell you that I was able to
clear and pass my cissp and ccsp
certification exams on the first attempt
after taking the course course I must
say was packed with practical examples
it was led by highly skilled certified
instructors with many companies before
as a security analyst and architect on a
contract basis but I needed some
stability which I got with the job I
just started with infosis as a cyber
security consultant happened on first
thanks for watching and stay tuned for
more from Simply staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
in the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here